- [Mark] Okay, Maggie.
Maggie, where you originally?
- Northern Virginia,
just outside of Washington, DC.
- [Mark] And, what brought
you out here to skid row?
- [Maggie] Well, what brought me
to Los Angeles was treatment, originally.
And that was in 2015.
- [Mark] Which drug?
- At that time it was alcohol.
I've been using drugs
since I was, I mean, well,
if you include weed and alcohol, like 15.
But, I've been using heroin
on and off since I was 18.
I was able to put it
down for about 12 years
but I became a raging
alcoholic and crack smoker.
So then in 2014 I was in a
horrific motorcycle accident.
And a man with cataracts
hit me from behind,
the irony of this story
is that I'd offered, 60 days sober,
got offered to go to the bar that night
and I chose to go home.
And I got hit and thrown
from my motorcycle
and opened my eyes when
I laying on the ground.
And the car's still
coming straight for me.
If I had just gotten knocked off my bike,
I would had a broken
wrist and some scrapes.
But, I'm lying there and the
car literally runs me over
with its front and rear passenger tires,
like I'm a speed bump.
Luckily I'm blessed because
it shattered my pelvis.
But, a little bit lower,
I would've been paralyzed,
and a little but higher
I would have been dead.
I mean, you can't even
tell looking at me today.
- [Mark] No, I would never suspect.
- And my pelvis was shattered.
Only 9% of the time when
the bones break in that way,
if you don't die on impact,
they rupture an internal organ
and that didn't happen either.
So, that was in 2014.
And 2015, like, right after that,
like, as soon as I got to the hospital,
I was like give me a
bottle, like fuck this.
Like, forget it.
Like, forget sobriety.
And I was on all kinds of opiates.
I mean, they had the
button, they had everything.
I mean, literally, my pelvis was shattered
and that's the term in the ER report.
And, at this point, I was
actually a professional
Broadway jazz dancer.
I danced in the company of Chicago.
I've danced with Lion King
and my pelvis didn't heal correctly.
So, now I've got one leg
that's shorter than the other.
And dancers, if their hips aren't aligned,
basically their career's done.
So, that was also another
major, you know, blow.
And, like I said, at this point
I hadn't done heroin in
about 9 and a half, 10 years.
And I didn't abuse the
prescription medication,
but I drank like a fish.
And so I came out here to
Palm Springs for treatment.
And then I got sent to an IOP
in a sober living out here.
And I was sober for a year and a half.
And after that year and a half
I'd had a botched surgery at John Hopkins.
They told me my pelvis was healed,
they took out all the
hardware and they were wrong.
My pelvis broke away, the right side,
broke away from the base of my spine.
And they took out the bolt, if you will,
the screw, that was holding that together.
So, for a while
my right leg was not attached
to the rest of my body
and I had to have a fusion
at the base of my spine.
And the recovery from that
surgery was hellacious.
I had extreme nerve damage,
I had a pool of blood dry under incision.
And then I was having
excruciating nerve pain
going down my leg.
And there's, I mean,
no amount of opiates will touch that pain.
There's really nothing
other than Gabapentin
and maybe Lyrica that touches nerve pain.
But, this was so excruciating
and the surgeon was like,
"There's nothing wrong.
There's nothing wrong."
You know, "It's just nerve pain,"
head of ortho at Cedars.
And I relapsed after a
year and a half sober.
My boyfriend was moving all of his stuff
out of our apartment while I
was having the procedure done.
And they found a softball size mass
on my pelvis that no
one had told me about.
You know, I never got angry at God
when the accident happened.
I wasn't, literally, before
the second tire went over me,
I said, "Okay, God, here we go."
And not, you know, like, "All
right, I'm going to die,"
just like, "You're with
me, no matter what."
And at this point I was angry.
I was distraught.
Why did you save my life
to make it this hell?
Why? Like, what?
You know, I gave glory to
God and profess your name.
Like, why?
Why?
And so I relapsed.
I Googled, literally,
Googled on where to find
drugs in Los Angeles,
'cause I hadn't used here.
And it sent me to MacArthur park.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
(both laugh)
Yeah, it's cleaned up a little bit now.
(Maggie drowns out Mark)
Yeah.
Anyway, well, that's where I went.
It's a lot cleaner now than it was,
this was in 2017,
about February, 2017.
And, you know, I relapsed on heroin.
My drugs of choice are
alcohol, heroin and crack.
And I just I threw it all away,
I was so emotionally broken at that point.
And, so
(Maggie clears her throat)
since that surgery in 2017,
and the fact that I was already an addict,
coupled with the fact that I
got a large amount of money.
Because the accident was my fault.
- [Mark] I was going to ask you that, but-
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You might get some settle-
And
so
I relapsed
and I have not been able to get it back
since 2017.
In the past I've had-
My first time in treatment
was when I was 18.
The third time I went to
treatment at 20 years old,
I got two years sober.
And then I've had like nine months
and then that year and a half.
But, since that surgery,
I just haven't been able to get it back.
Got really bad chronic pain.
And, you know, if we want
to do statistic wise,
like, even lower for
people with chronic pain.
I'm not saying that it can't be done,
because there are people that do it.
And I got sober.
I ended up down in skid row
about two years ago for the first time.
And, like I said, I had a lot of money,
I didn't have to sell myself for drugs,
I didn't have to-
Robbing, stealing's never
really been my thing.
If I need to, I'll prostitute myself
because I can accept
responsibility for that.
And I'm also not going
to have someone else
try and control me.
You know, there's guys that want to, like,
dangle drugs in front of you
and I'd much rather go
out and make it myself
and compromise myself rather
than compromise anyone else.
I don't know if-
I feel like there's some
odd integrity in that.
Well, for whatever that's worth
if that makes any sense to anybody.
Sorry, I'm kind of jumping
all over the place.
So, I ended up living
down here for three months
and I met a girl that I
call my skid row angel.
She was in a situation
where she had been beaten
and needed to get out of it.
And I just did the next right thing
and helped someone, you
know, have a place to stay.
I said, you can stay in this hotel room,
pay that guest for you if you need to.
And, I don't think I'd be alive today,
down here, if it wasn't for her.
And, you know, I really
got blessed in that way.
But, I stayed down here for three months-
- [Mark] By helping her, it helped you.
- Basically.
And I just did the next right thing.
And
then I went to treatment.
I mean, I've been in and out of treatment
for the last two and a half years.
But, I wasn't done, I
knew that I wasn't done.
I went because my sister
was absolutely distraught.
She's 50.
She's my stepsister, technically.
Her mother died when I
was 16 of breast cancer.
And she, since then,
has taken on the role of
being like a sister mom.
And, she was tracking me
everywhere I went down here.
I mean, I let her, you
know, like, safety wise but-
- [Mark] So, that was your
mom as well, who passed away?
- It was my stepmother.
- [Mark] Your stepmother.
- Mm hm.
A little bit background,
my parents got divorced when I was-
When my dad asked for a divorce
when I was like not even
like six months old.
He was planning on leaving,
and then my mother got pregnant.
And his father had done
that to his mother.
So, he thought that it was better to stay
until after the birth,
and then ask for one.
Which, you know, whatever.
And so my parents didn't
think they could have kids.
I was a bit of an accident.
I have a brother who's
adopted from Santiago, Chile.
My mother got pregnant
when she was younger
before abortions were legal.
And she did what she had to do.
So, because of that
she thought that she
was permanently damaged
and then I came along.
And
so, my dad left
(Maggie clears throat her)
and he was-
I'm half Mexican and there's
a term that we call mujeriego,
he's a womanizer.
And in his prime, he was
a bit of a womanizer.
So, he was cheating on my mother
with several different women,
but then he ultimately
married one of them.
And that is my sister's mom.
And she is basically, it's
like, I almost had two mothers
because my mom will give
you the shirt off her back.
She's the most caring woman,
she's a retired elementary
school principal.
And she loves just anybody,
just off the bat, just because.
But, as far as her independence
and strength as a woman,
that's not her forte, it's just not.
And I got that.
I get my independence and my
strength from my stepmother.
So, she passed away when I was 16.
And my sister has kind of been
like a sister mom since then.
So, I went to treatment
because I couldn't listen to how-
I couldn't put her through that anymore,
but I wasn't done.
And that was May of last year.
And then I relapsed
maybe two or three months
after being sober.
I was on the East Coast at this point
in a program in Baltimore.
And
I just, I wasn't done.
And my parents sent me,
or I chose to come back out here
to where it had some success.
And that was in January of this year.
And, I sat in the program
and knew I wasn't done.
I still had some money in the bank
and I chose to come back down here.
I rent at the hotel I stayed at before.
And I lived down here
from January until July.
And the money ran out.
Well, as much as I-
Anyway, there's nothing.
The money ran out, let's
just put it that way.
And I went to treatment just
like I said I was going to,
and this was in July.
And I was in treatment for a month
and I got about two months sober.
And then about a month ago
I couldn't even necessarily
tell you what happened,
normally when I relapse, I see it coming.
I see it,
I know it's going to come,
I understand it.
I went to church on Sunday morning.
A guy had hurt me really
bad the night before.
And I felt like-
Like, this is a guy that
took advantage of me,
the same guy that left me
when I was when I was going
through that procedure
and I relapsed.
He claims he's got seven years sober,
but he stole my medication and like-
It's just all messy.
And he and I began talking again
when I was sober this last time.
And he told me that he didn't
really want to be with me,
he wanted to slow things down.
And this was somebody who chased after me,
wanted to propose to me
when I was at like my lowest point.
And I want nothing to do with him
because he took such advantage.
And I thought, "If he
doesn't even love me,
if I'm not even good
enough for him to love me
then what's the point?"
I mean, he should be begging
for me to grace him with his presence.
I know that sounds egotistical,
but it just really hit.
And, like I said, I went to church.
I went for some wings afterwards,
football was on at Buffalo Wild Wings.
I ordered a beer, one beer
later, I'm back down here.
And,
I mean,
I could go right back
but that's what I always do.
And right now I feel like
I have to take the time to-
I can't do the end now,
I can't disappoint my
family like that anymore.
I can't do it to myself.
It's so demoralizing.
The rooms of AA are
supposed to be welcoming
and they're not always that way.
And I just have to
figure out whether or not
I'm ever gonna want to be sober.
Or whether I need to figure out a way
to just live my life while I'm doing this,
because I'm just not going to put it down
to be honest with myself.
How I started using in the first place.
You know, there's a-
The suburbs can be just
as messy as the ghetto,
we just put on a better facade.
At five years old my
brother began molesting me,
my adopted brother.
And, at this point he has
so many mental issues.
He's developmentally about
five, seven years behind
his actual age,
which isn't that big of
a deal now that he's 40.
But, back then it was about 12,
you know, it was a big deal.
His mother was on
everything under the sun,
at 13 years old, in Chile,
during the pregnancy
and gave birth.
And then he was in the
orphanage for like five years,
which is a long time.
I actually have a friend from high school
who was in the exact same
orphanage as my brother,
adopted right at birth.
And then my brother-
And it's just-
It's almost like how they
used to give kids opium
in the twenties,
because they didn't know
it was bad for them.
They didn't know how to handle
his emotional disorders.
They didn't, and they, you know,
did the best that they could, I guess.
So, I was constantly getting blamed
for stuff that he was doing,
so I was terrified to say anything.
You know, I just thought
I would get blamed.
You know, my parents couldn't fathom
that he had this many issues.
And so, you know,
I finally said something to my mom.
And, yeah, after he ultimately raped me,
he would call it tickling.
I've also seen my brother-
We went to pick him up for
his weekend with him mom
and he didn't want to go.
So, he jumped out of the
car and my dad told my mom
I had to go wait in the house.
He comes in through the back door
with a big butcher knife,
gets on top of my mom on the couch
and takes it to her throat.
And I was maybe nine years old
and I just was screaming, bloody murder.
I've seen him attempt to kill probably
every member of my family.
He's attempted to set my arm
on fire when I was three.
And
it's just, you know, that-
I didn't even remember the abuse
until I was in high school
at a church retreat.
And the first time I did heroin
I felt like I didn't have to
worry about anything anymore.
I didn't have to be the
mediator between my parents
so that I could make sure
that I got my needs met,
so I can make sure that I
had money for the school trip
or this or that because
mom didn't want talk to dad
and dad want to talk to mom.
And after my stepmother died when I was 16
my dad became very
selfish because he'd felt
that he'd been a caregiver for so long,
he didn't need to anymore.
He figured the fact that
he had a special needs son
and a 16 year old daughter.
And so it's just-
I was 18 years old, I didn't even know
that you could do heroin any
other way than shooting it.
I was dating this guy
and I tried it and it was
an instant love affair.
And that, like I said, that was 18.
And I dealt with a lot
of those emotional issues
in my first couple of treatment centers.
And I think that's part of the reason why
I didn't go back to it,
even though I did drink
and do other stuff.
But, I didn't go back to
that particular substance.
And
then the accident happened
and I just kind of thought, "Okay, God,"
you know, I'd, kind of, met my quota
for trauma for my life, you know?
All right, we're good,
we got it out of the way,
okay, fine, cool.
You know, I'm good to go.
And then the accident happened.
And, like I said, my pelvis was shattered.
Now, you know, that no one
was raping me in that sense
it brought up a whole bunch of-
It reopened all of those wounds.
And I mean, I didn't know,
you know, I didn't think that, you know,
getting run over by car
was going to, you know,
bring up some of the
abuse, everything again.
I felt like I was just
being re traumatized.
And
so it's-
You know, I had my fair share of,
you know, like everybody does-
I don't like to compare.
Some people are like,
"Oh my trauma's worse than your trauma."
Trauma's trauma.
I don't know how you cope
or relate to your trauma
and how that affects you
and you don't know how that affects me.
Something that doesn't affect me at all
might devastate someone else.
And I do look at my
compassion as a blessing
out of what happened with my brother.
Unlike your average rape
victim or rape abuser
where you can just X them out of your life
and everybody hates them.
And, you know, Dad comes
to the rescue and like,
you know, how dare they.
You can't get rid of them, you know?
And you have to figure
out a way to cohabitate.
And today he's gay.
And, you know, it's hard
for him to even admit
what happened.
He has.
He has his own struggles with alcohol
and we have a very minimal relationship.
And I'm able to set boundaries
and I just really don't speak
to him for the most part.
- [Mark] Who do you speak
to still in your family?
- My sister, my mother.
I don't speak to my
father while I'm using.
I barely talked to my
father in the last year.
I was supposed to meet
him at a baseball game
last labor day,
and instead I got high.
And-
Yeah.
- [Mark] Is he out here?
- No, my family is all back-
Well, my sister's in Seattle
and the rest of my family's in Virginia.
- [Mark] So you were back home?
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Yeah, this is when I was in Baltimore.
I had, like, those few months.
And I mean, they just, like,
my sister says that I'm a drug addict,
but I'm a good person.
And, she's like, "That's
what makes it so difficult.
If you're a horrible person, like,
it would be so easy to hate you."
You know?
"Or to be bad at what you're doing."
And I don't even-
I don't necessarily use
today because I hate myself,
I don't.
I'm not entirely certain why I use.
I don't know, I mean, I've
been to 16 treatment centers
that doesn't include
detoxes and outpatients.
And, you know, I really thought this time,
like, I was in a great space.
I just didn't see this coming.
I didn't.
And that's what, I guess,
has gotten me so thrown
for a loop right now.
- [Mark] What do you think
the solution might be
to get clean for you?
If it isn't,
then you just hate yourself
like a lot of people here do.
Though, their standards are so low
that this environment and drug abuse
and all that works for them
'cause it's where they
subconsciously grasp.
But, for you, you know, you were a dancer,
you were very accomplished.
So, for you it almost seems
like a very different animal.
(Maggie sighs)
- People give me a start here.
People view me as a sucker too,
but people-
I feel like, you know, I try
to do the next right thing.
And like, maybe if I wasn't here,
like, there was a woman,
she's my brother's age,
and she got robbed of her bag
of clothes and everything.
And, this was back in like March.
She was freezing outside of the bank
and she never asked me for drugs,
she never asked me for money.
I don't think she'd ask me for cigarettes.
And, you know, I saw her
one night and, you know,
and I went to my hotel room
and got her blankets and everything like,
who would have done that?
And I kind of feel good about myself.
My struggle is when I get clean,
they want us to sit in programs
for like the first year,
"Don't do anything,
don't get involved"-
I can't do that.
I've been such a waste
of space for so long
that I feel like they
really need to look at more
of how they do it in like Portugal,
where they give people a purpose.
The opposite of addiction is connection.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's what I was going to-
- Mm hm, and the other
part of it's purpose.
You know, addicts and alcoholics
are such passionate people.
And we, you know, we've got
so much to offer, we feel.
And we care so much that what do we do
with all this extra energy
that maybe other people are like,
"Why do you even give a crap?"
You know?
Or, how does that affect you?
Like, I don't even care,
don't let it affect you.
And, my thing is like,
I got to get back in
and doing something.
But, instead it's like you've
got the insurance systems
where they want to keep you in treatment
because they're making money.
You've got treatment centers
that are paying you to go.
They've got treatment centers
where people are coming in
that work for the treatment center,
got hired by the treatment centers
to convinced you to relapse
so that you have to go back
to the treatment center
and then all over again
and get all of the insurance money.
- [Mark] I'm listening to your story
and certainly you've been through a lot.
So there's that, but you
also seem to have the resolve
and where with all to
do great things in life,
which a lot of these
people I've spoken to,
kind of, just don't for
a multitude of reasons.
And, it almost seems
like what might save you
is a great relationship with somebody.
You know?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I don't know what
the solution is to that.
I don't know where you
go about finding that.
But, miracles like that do happen.
- They do.
- [Mark] 'Cause the thing is, like,
going to another treatment,
same thing, that's not going to do it.
Finding something to replace
your creative outlet-
- I mean I've got ideas.
- [Mark] That might be helpful,
but then in combination
with someone in your life
could be good.
- I would have to agree with that.
You know, because I do stay sober, like,
when I was with the guy for, you know,
I had a year and a half.
And then
when things like that
fall apart, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, which they do.
- Which they do.
And it's like how-
I also tend, in relationships,
do a lot of work on my romantic,
well, just in general relationships.
And one of my character defects is that
I will give and give and give of myself
and then expect the other
person to do the same,
and they don't.
And I sacrifice my own
needs because I'm like,
"Okay, well, it's my turn to sacrifice.
I'm going to need them at some point."
And, you know,
this is just what you do in relationships.
And then time after time,
I'm not met with the same
love and care and concern
and acceptance that I met them with.
And that happens in a
lot of my relationships.
You know, not just
romantic but friendship.
And so, you know, that's
something I have to look at
because I didn't realize
that I have unrealistic
expectations of people.
- [Mark] Yeah, well that's
on you to figure out.
- Right.
- [Mark] You can point
the finger on other people
all day long.
- Right.
- [Mark] But, that's ultimately
something you're doing.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] Well, thank you so
much for telling me your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Very moving.
And you're very different from
everyone I've spoken to here.
You don't look the part
and you also clearly aren't
your typical skid row person.
- I get that, yeah.
- [Mark] And good luck,
thank you for being patient.
- Yep.